Sir. How do we solve
this? Unleashed a quantum
hello world.
It's so Raj and quantum machine learning.
It sounds like the final class in a
phd program doesn't it? In this video,
I'll demonstrate a few examples of
how both quantum computing and machine
learning can be used together to
solve some really hard problems,
but before we go there,
we need to get more familiarized
with the field of quantum mechanics.
This is the collection of scientific
laws that describe the behavior of
subatomic particles on
endlessly fascinating subject
that's been notoriously
difficult to master and somewhat
controversial even for physicists.
It all started in the 17th century when
scientists were trying to figure out the
properties of light and rocking
crazy facial hair. At first,
Isaac Newton thought that light
only consisted of tiny particles.
Christian Huygens thought
it was made up of waves,
but Newton became puzzled by the wave
like phenomena of light interference.
Interference is when two waves super
posed to form a resulting wave of greater,
lower or the same amplitude.
It turned out they were both right and
this resulted in the wave theory of light,
which states that light is both made up
of tiny particles and made up of waves
vibrating up and down perpendicular
to the direction that it travels.
I'm signed later discovered that these
tiny particles called photons consist of
energy inspired by this Niels Bohr
came up with a new model for an Adam,
the basic unit of all
matter in the universe.
His model stated that an atom contains
a small positively charged nucleus
surrounded by electrons that travel in
circular orbits around each other like a
solar system.
Each orbit has its own energy
level and changes to that energy,
like the transition of an electron
from one orbit to another.
Around the nucleus of an atom
happens in discreet Quanta.
The phrase quantum leap refers to the
movement from one discrete energy level to
another. With no transition.
It's abrupt bore.
Realize that because the movement
of an electron was not progressive,
it just disappeared from one orbit
and appeared in the next orbit.
With no intermediary state,
the amount of energy at that level
couldn't be further subdivided.
That's why he called it Quanta, a
minimum quantity of energy. Clearly,
scientists,
we're beginning to figure out that the
rules of classical mechanics did not
apply at the subatomic level,
but it gets even more interesting.
Simulation confirmed.
Consider the question,
why does it an electron
have an intermediate state
physicist Lewis to Brawley
answered that question when he explained
that matter can exhibit both particle
and wave like nature,
just like light.
This wave like nature of
electrons requires them to
obtain certain wavelengths
which are allowed for them to fit in an
orbit and within that orbit electrons
can exist throughout,
not just in a single spot
because of its wavelike nature.
Other physicists were paying attention
to this and contributed more discoveries.
Heisenberg,
not the breaking bad one for example,
later proposed his uncertainty principle
which stated that the position and
velocity of a particle cannot both
be measured exactly at the same time,
even in theory.
He later helped develop the Copenhagen
interpretation of quantum mechanics,
which stated that a quantum particle
doesn't exist in one state or another.
Instead, it's an all of its
possible states simultaneously.
It's only when we observe this state that
a quantum particle is forced to choose
one probability and that's the
state we observe. That's right.
It stating that reality exists in
a certain way until we measure it.
It's reactive to conscious observation.
Pretty incredible stuff.
This states,
by the way of existing in all possible
states simultaneously is called
superposition.
The Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics was theoretically proven by a
famous thought experiment
called Schrodinger's cat.
In this thought experiment of physicists
puts a cat in a box along with some
radioactive material and a
device for detecting radiation.
The is designed so that when it
senses the decay of the material,
it triggers a hammer which will
break a flask containing acid,
which will kill the cat evil Aaf,
but to eliminate any certainty about the
cat Speight the experiment takes place
within an hour long enough so some of
the radioactive material could decay,
but short enough so that it's
also possible none could.
While the cat is sealed in the box,
it comes to exist in an unknowable state.
It can't be observed,
so it instead exists in a super
imposed state of both life and death.
Until we open the box
and observed the cat,
it has half a probability of being dead
and half a probability of being alive.
The state of the cat is tied to its
situation and can be considered a form of
quantum entanglement.
This is a phenomenon by which the quantum
states of two or more objects can be
described in reference to each other.
You can't describe the state of
one without referencing the other,
and that same property applies even when
these particles are separated by any
amount of space.
Einstein called this spooky
action at a distance.
Clearly quantum mechanics is awesome
and there are a lot of different
interpretations of it.
Even though the Copenhagen
interpretation is the most popular Tldr,
the laws of nature at the sub atomic level
or different than at any other level.
So how can we leverage this to
possibly solve some hard problems?
About 40 years ago.
The popular physicist Richard Fineman
propose that in order to be able to
simulate physics on a machine properly,
that includes the laws of both
classical and quantum mechanics,
we'd need to create a kind of quantum
computer, classical computers,
the ones we all use,
perform operations using classical bits,
which are represented as binary data.
Either a zero or a one,
but what if we could have a bit represent
both one and zero at the same time?
What happens then?
Well,
quantum mechanics tells us that this
kind of super position of both states is
indeed possible.
At the subatomic level.
The basic unit of a quantum
computer is called a cubit.
These cubits can be physically represented
by quantum particles that can occupy
two states simultaneously.
We could use a photon or an electron,
and rather than having these cubits
interact, how classical bits do,
we can leverage the idea of quantum
entanglement to allow these cubits to
interact with each other in all
new interesting ways. Nowadays,
big technology companies like IBM,
Google and Microsoft as well as well
funded startups like we're dedi computing
are all racing to build these exotic
machines to see how we can use the quantum
concepts of super
position and entanglement,
the both speed up existing algorithms
and create entirely new classes of
algorithms.
This involves a lot of computer science
theory across a lot of different
subfields, but let's specifically talk
about its effect on machine learning.
Firstly, quantum devices can be
used to accelerate machine learning.
Current quantum technologies resemble
special purpose hardware like a six rather
than the general purpose CPU.
There are hardwired to implement a
limited class of quantum algorithms.
More advanced quantum devices can be
programmed to run simple quantum circuits
just like FPGA.
Yes,
we know that both a six and f pgas offer
benefits in machine learning as well as
Gpu, CPU and tps. Therefore,
a quantum processor could theoretically
be added to this mix of specialized AI
hardware to help us advance towards Agi
by creating an entirely new field of
machine learning.
Similar to how GPU is contributed to the
deep learning renaissance that started
a couple years ago.
Interestingly,
it turns out that mathematical
optimization is an
important task in quantum
mechanics just like it
is in machine learning.
Physicists are interested in finding
the point of lowest energy in a high
dimensional energy landscape.
In fact,
one of the first tasks for
quantum computers orchestrated
by the company D-Wave
involved optimization.
There are quantum annealer was
used to solve classification tasks.
More recently,
the hybrid quantum classical technique
of variational circuits has been proposed
where a quantum device is used to evaluate
a hard to compute cost function while
a classical device performs an
optimization based on this information.
And what about those
massively parallelized matrix
multiplication operations
that neural networks required Gpu
for? Well, in quantum computing,
the bottleneck to doing
this is data in coding.
In order to use them for linear Algebra,
we have to first load the large
matrix onto the quantum device,
which is nontrivial,
but a quantum gate does execute a
multiplication of an exponentially large
matrix with a similarly large vector.
We could even think of a quantum gate
as a linear layer of a giant neural net
and exciting insight that could
lead to novel neural architectures.
There's also the idea of sampling.
We can think of quantum computers
as samplers that prepare a class of
distributions called quantum states
and sample from them with measurements.
We could explore how samples from quantum
devices can be used to train machine
learning models. Sample based training
for Bolton machines is one example.
Another idea is colonel evaluation kernel
methods use machine learning models
based on a distance measure between
data points call the kernel.
Quantum devices can be used
to estimate certain kernels,
including the ones hard to
compute classically by estimating.
The inner products have two
high dimensional quantum states.
So the estimates from a quantum device
can be fed into a standard colonel
method,
like a support vector machine.
Although inference and
training are done classically,
they can be augmented
with the quantum device.
So we can think of the first generation
of quantum computers as partially
programmable special purpose devices
that can accelerate certain tasks in
machine learning,
just like gps did for deep learning,
quantum computers can help speed up some
existing machine learning models allow
for the creation of never before
possible models. And likewise,
machine learning can help quantum devices
learn new quantum algorithms rather
than having researchers try
to figure them out themselves.
Lots of work is happening right
now in this field, and if you want,
you can try out your own quantum algorithm
on both real and simulated quantum
devices.
Links will be in the video description.
Thanks so much for watching my video.
Hit subscribe and I'll come visit
you and your dreams tonight. For now,
I've got to get disentangled,
so thanks for watching.